Now that their sound manager is initialized. The next thing we need to take
care of is actually loading our sound effects so that they're ready to play.
Now the Web Audio API is similar to the image loading process that we use for
Canvas. We only load images asynchronously. Now for essentially the same
reasons. So what we're going to do is check if the sound has already been
loaded. And if it is, we call our call back function. If its not we kick off a
load in the form of an XML a to the p request, and then assign a callback
function for once the load has completed. Finally we're going to return to
actual clip data either way. Now here's some skeleton code to get you up and
running. What we'd like you to do is to fill in the code So let them performs
the Asynchronous loading that I just desribed